-Guys, it is time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-We do this thing
every week where I send out
a hashtag, and we ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
So, since "The Batman"
comes out tomorrow,
I sent out the hashtag
"MyDumbSuperpower."
And I asked you to describe
a funny or weird superpower
that you have.
Within minutes,
it was a trending topic,
so thank you for playing along.
Every week, we do this game,
and I appreciate it.
So, here are some of my favorite
"MyDumbSuperpower" responses
from you guys.
This first one is from
@NWI Irish96. He says...
-Ooh!
-That's impossible.
That is -- That's impossible.
Just go in and get one thing.
-Yeah.
-Can you carry that cart?
-I got three carts of stuff.
This one's from
@elise millsssss.
It's like five extra S's.
-Yeah.
-This is @elise millsssss.
She says...
You're -- you're --
you're a stupid face.
-Yeah.
-You're a stupid face.
Gosh! Why did I say
"stupid face"?
I couldn't top that one?
This one's from @JustMyTweet.
She says...
-Oh, nice!
-I have that same superpower.
This one's from @Brian Cronin.
He says...
-Oh.
-I think I can do it.
♪♪
That's Vanilla Ice.
That's Queen.
-Yeah.
-Did I get it?
-Yes, you did.
-Wow!
[ Ding ]
-How -- Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How did I get that?
-Because you knew.
-Shakers.
-And Vanilla Ice said,
"Din-din-din-din-da-da-din-din."
-I know -- Yeah, so, Queen is,
"Din-din-din-da-da-din."
And his is, "Ding-ding-da-da-
ding-da-da-ding-ding."
-Right, right.
-Let's hear it again.
♪♪
-That's Vanilla Ice.
Shaker, 808.
-Right.
And then --
♪♪
That's just --
-Yeah.
-You're saying Vanilla Ice
does it with a Shake Weight?
Is that what you said?
-Could be, yeah.
-Could be. I don't know.
-This one's from @SomethingPork.
-Mmm!
-Huh?
-You love pork.
-I love pork.
-You pull your own pork?
-Pull my own pork
all the time when I'm alone.
[ Laughter ]
-I know you love food.
-I love food.
-Yeah.
Pizza. Mmm!
-Pork.
-He says he has...
-Yes!
-That's genius.
That's impossible.
♪♪
He's either a
genius or a serial killer.
-Yeah.
This one's from @Greencard74.
They say...
Uh, did you say...
10 items or less?
Well, alright, hold on.
I got to make a decision here.
I have 13 items.
Well, maybe I'll make --
Well, three Starbursts
count as one item, right?
Kind of?
-Wait. Let me get my coupons
out of my bag.
-Zip!
[ Imitates coupons flipping ]
That's your coupons?
Oh, yeah, definitely.
I don't even have a dog.
I just think I should
get this dog food
because it's a good deal.
-It's such a good bargain.
-Yeah.
This one's from
@rstingbrittface.
[ Laughs ]
That's funny.
She says...
"Hi."
-"What?!"
What?! Shut up!"
-"You're the worst, Mom.
You don't get me!"
-Is that Pee-wee Herman Teen?
-Yeah.
It's like Pee-wee,
but it's a little deeper voice.
[ As Pee-wee Herman ]
But this is Pee-wee right here.
[ Laughs ]
[ Normal voice ]
This one's from @kansasbradbury.
He says...
Fantastic.
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more of
our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.
Thanks for doing this.